[Music]
chuck got another explainer video for
you right on i'm about it i i know a lot
of stuff but not i don't know everything
okay all right what are you just you're
just rubbing in my face now no so today
we're going to talk about space debris
and i you know i have like an amateur
level knowledge of this but when you
want to go for the big guns we got to go
to a friend of star talk more about ja
yeah morgan welcome back to star talk
hey it's beautiful to be here with both
of you once again more about you are a
professor of aerospace engineering at
the university of texas at austin and
you have special interest in space
debris and this is crap that's left over
from our rocket launches possibly even
asteroids at space debris that we didn't
cause but there's one in particular that
we a few weeks ago it was reported that
there was a wayward spacex booster
that was on a collision course with the
moon that was that's going to hit march
4th
a later intel would show maybe it's not
spacex but it's a booster from china
could you update us on this
yeah you know interestingly enough um
you got amateur telescope people
observing this object and apparently at
first like you said the hypothesis was
that yep indeed this is one of spacex's
rockets and it's on the way to the moon
it's going to crash there on march 4th
woe is me
uh but then
looks like the people that discovered
that this was a spacex rocket
turns out that they misidentified the
rocket and
then they said hey it looks like it
might be chinese
now of course
which everybody else said of course
right right right of course what does it
sound like
doesn't it sound like he who smelt it
dealt it like everyone's trying to blame
it on somebody else what's going on here
yeah how can we be that uncertain well
you know the interesting thing that i
like telling people is that
most of the stuff up there because it's
dead it doesn't report its identity so
when you see a dot in the sky
there's uh uncertainty there's zambia
it's a bogey yeah it's a pokemon
wow
wow so now how what allows you
to say because clearly both rockets went
up
okay they both spacex rockets
they clearly both had boosters so now
how do you know that this was indeed the
chinese rocket
i love this question okay so here's the
deal
because these things are either
you know too far or too small or
whatever whenever you see these things
in a telescope image it's a dot of light
like you don't see the whole thing the
size the shape and all this other stuff
you just you don't see flags you don't
see
that's a damn good telescope though if i
do
i'd love about a dozen of those yeah but
i can't find them anywhere so so here's
the thing right so you see a dot of
light and you say well based on how this
dot of light is behaving i think
it may have been this that or the other
but the thing that lets us know
whether or not it's chinese or not is
sometimes you can collect reflected
light or photons in different
wavelengths we can we call those uh
spectral analysis
and
based on
how the reflected light
is interacting with the material of the
object a friend of mine in tucson said
hey i looked at the material properties
and the material properties better match
a chinese rocket than the spacex rocket
is this matching reflection off of the
metal or over the paint that's used on
the fuselage
both wow this is like space junk csi
right
[Laughter]
forensics multi-transaction that's right
exactly
wow
okay so can they can they do can they
implicate which launch it was
i think that one's tougher just because
you have to try to assess
how does the material age in space to
get some idea of the longevity how long
it's been up there but uh yeah i mean i
think that they have some some rough
guesses
so does the orbit also play into the
kind of investigation because i mean
once something's up there right it has
its own
you know unique orbit right
yeah it has its unique orbit chuck but
at the same time we send satellites kind
of to same places
and so
so so the the general orbital
neighborhood of some of these things
they tend to be fairly consistent so
holy stuff wait a minute okay now you're
scaring it it's crowded he's saying yeah
i was gonna say now you scare me i was
about to say and i almost said it how
much
is up there
how much
is up there man
yeah so so let me tell you about how
much is up there
so
so right now we track about 40 or 50 000
things ranging in size from cell phone
to the space station and about 4 000 of
those are things that work and
everything else is garbage oh oh god
oh
let me just say this human beings if
you're in the sound of my voice
you're awful you're just awful okay
we can do better yeah we could do so
much better that's crazy
all right so i'd expect some of those
would burn up on re-entry to earth's
atmosphere so that can't be all the ones
you're talking about otherwise
that would have cleaned up by now
absolutely and so only the ones that are
in very low earth orbit just you know
several hundred miles above the earth's
surface those are the ones that
eventually come in re-enter
but
the rocket bodies
they don't all like burn up in the
atmosphere some chunks of those things
survive and make it all the way to the
earth's surface and that's kind of scary
uh just a little
you know
it kind of reminds me of like why i
never walk under scaffolding here in new
york city yeah neither do i it's a
little paranoid but it's true
that's how i feel because how do i know
there's not a guy up there who's like
hungover or still drunk from the night
before who's just like oh my tool belt
what a shame i just killed that guy
right okay so barbara you all right i
get you that we have leftover junk in
orbit but this one
is landing on the moon
so give me a trajectory that gets us
from earth orbit to the moon yeah so i
think that once you start sending uh
things to the geostationary belt and
beyond that um depending on how the
planets line up that gravity kind of
tweaking some of these things gain
enough energy
to go into sufficiently long
longer distances or orbits that get them
out to the moon it doesn't take that
much energy to go to the moon let me ask
this for both of you because i learned
from neil what geosynchronous orbit is
but this is the first time i've ever
heard of the
geostationary belt
what is that i mean yeah yeah okay it
sounds like a diet
[Laughter]
you better tighten that geostationary
belt let me tell you tighten that
geostationary belt exactly
look so um i think the better thing to
call it is geosynchronous because that
just means that anything in this
goldilocks orbit kind of takes it about
24 hours to go around once the
geostationary means that it's
geosynchronous and it's staying in the
same place on the earth's equator so
that's a tougher thing to do only things
that you can control
actively with thrusters can do that but
when things die
they stay geosynchronous but not
geostationary so chuck also for
geosynchronous you can have satellites
that orbit twice per earth rotation or
three times and it's still synchronized
but at a different phase than one to one
so that would still be considered
synchronous yeah but stationary he
nailed it it's like it's that one little
tiny belt
and it's over the equator and and and
more about low earth orbit you said a
couple hundred miles up geostationary is
how high up
like thirty six thousand kilometers
okay okay now and how about for us who
went to public
schools for me now
let's
let's just say it's it's over 20 000
miles okay there you go 20 000 miles up
public schools
so i just realized all along i've been
helping you out for being a public
school person given all the distances
miles then we get like a full up
engineer in the house and now he's
he don't play he don't play okay like
okay
all right so the energy required to get
to geostationary
compared with the energy to get to the
moon you said there's not much of a
difference there
exactly i mean we're talking maybe
hundreds of meters per second a
difference of of change in velocity so
it's not that much more
so now there's not a lot of things that
are going to hit the moon
can we at least
learn something from
a
lunar impact by watching this thing
go and hit the moon here's the thing
chuck
in 2019
four things hit the moon one of them was
on purpose and it wasn't news so this is
where i start scratching my head it's
like this people have been doing this
things have been impacting the moon and
now it's like a thing but yeah we should
learn not to do that anymore
that's what to learn so we've we've got
a cottage industry among my fellow astro
folk where they observe the unlit side
of the moon that's facing the earth and
they observe every night very carefully
look for sparks of light and these would
just be meteors hitting and
and uh getting destroyed on impact but
more about i had read that it's going to
hit on the back side of the moon not on
the front side so nobody's going to see
this
right exactly unless you are like over
there already look at that
just like this
the tardigrades are gonna observe it
shot the moon in the ass
that's terrible
that is terrible man
all right so it's gonna happen more
often and and and what's i mean what's
the future of this in the in like a
couple of minutes we got left yeah i
think it just says we're littering uh
you know as we're exploring space other
celestial bodies we're good at littering
so we're just going to keep on doing
that you know it's horrible what we need
is a space native american
out there in the space suit
and let one single team
and tell the world
stop littering space
see i just dated myself because nobody
knows what that even means
that's from
1970 71 chuck that's a long time ago
so there you go
another explainer video this one on
space debris and chuck you know we're
going to do from now on what's that
we're gonna introduce guest explainers
okay for the explainer videos now will
they be will they be scientists or
they're just
guests
random people on the street exactly no
now here's george from the bronx
hey i'm from the bronx okay don't talk
so
more about your field is so
it's so rich
in garbage
that's exactly why i want to do this
that's right
you had me at hello
you are so full of trash we want to hear
more of you uh
that's what we'll call the explainer
it'll be called
trash talking with more
there you go
chuck chuck's got it okay
so uh we'll look we'll look forward to
that and maybe that'll be a new feature
of star talk
get a bunch of experts who can talk
about stuff i can't and bring them on
yeah
and chuck our relationship will have to
work on separation anxieties for you
okay yeah because you know i'm already
feeling the anxiety right now so hey
i think you'll be fine chuck
so this has been yet another star talk
explainer video um introducing more baja
as a future
explainer
with chuck neil degrasse tyson here your
personal astrophysicist keep looking
[Music]
you